- [Instructor] Let's talk
about indoor air pollution.
I remember when I first heard
about indoor air pollution
in my AP environmental science class,
I was a little confused.
When I used to think of pollution,
I would think of images like this
or this.
But pollution is often invisible,
and it isn't just
restricted to the outdoors.
Indoor air pollutants can lead
to serious health conditions
and even death.
But there are ways to identify
and prevent indoor air pollution.
Let's take a look at an example.
This is Ava.
And let's say Ava, like many
other people in the world,
spends the majority of her time indoors.
She works, sleeps, cooks,
and eats in her home.
And lately, she's been
experiencing headaches
and she's been coughing.
A possible culprit is
indoor air pollution.
So, where could the indoor
air pollution be coming from?
Let's take a look at Ava's house.
Indoor air pollution can come from
many different kinds of sources,
both human-made and natural.
Ava's furniture, paneling, and carpets
could be releasing
volatile organic compounds,
which are often written down as VOCs,
and they basically include substances
that form gases at room
temperature, like formaldehyde.
Formaldehyde is used as an adhesive
in building materials and upholstery,
and it can get into the air.
This is the same stuff
that is used to embalm
and preserve dead bodies.
In other words, it's not
pleasant to breathe in.
The United States
Environmental Protection Agency
says that formaldehyde is one of the four
most dangerous air
pollutants in the country.
Formaldehyde can make
you dizzy and nauseated.
And if you're exposed to
enough of it, it can kill you.
Indoor air pollutants can also
come from Ava's house itself
in the form of particulates,
which are teeny-tiny particles
so small that they can
stay suspended in the air.
And they can be really dangerous
because they can travel
deep into the lungs
and damage cells.
One such particulate is asbestos.
It's actually, in my opinion,
a really cool substance.
It's an electrical insulator,
and it's fireproof and it's acid-proof.
And there was a time when
many houses were being built
with asbestos in its building insulation,
flooring, and roofing.
It's actually a natural
material that's mined,
and it has light fluffy fibers
that can be woven into cloth.
To me, it always looked like unicorn hair.
But really, it's more
like evil unicorn hair.
Each fiber can break
into microscopic pieces
that could scar your lungs
and lead to lung cancer
and other lung diseases.
Particulates in Ava's house
could also be coming from the paint.
Lead paint in Ava's house
could begin to chip away
and could suspend small
particles in the air.
These particles could
cause lead poisoning,
which can cause headaches
and nerve and brain damage.
The use of lead and
asbestos has been restricted
by many governments around the world,
but these materials can still
be found in older buildings.
Another way inside air can become polluted
is through combustion, which
is to say burning stuff.
Combustion can cause a
wide variety of pollutants
that can irritate lungs,
including carbon monoxide,
nitrogen oxides, sulfur
dioxide, and particulates.
One way that carbon monoxide
can build up inside a building
is from a poorly-maintained furnace.
Carbon monoxide molecules
have a secret weapon.
They can trick the proteins in your blood
into thinking they're oxygen.
This can cause asphyxiation,
which is when the body
cannot get enough oxygen,
and it can be deadly.
Ava should make sure that her
furnace is well maintained
and serviced regularly.
Combustion-related air pollution
doesn't just come from furnaces, though.
In less economically-developed countries,
families sometimes use open
fires for heating and cooking.
People often burn wood, peat,
and even coal inside homes
without the necessary
ventilation to circulate
and dilute the pollutants in the air.
Combustion-related air pollution
can also come from poorly
ventilated fireplaces
and tobacco smoke.
So, what could Eva do to reduce
combustion-related air pollution?
Well, she could open the windows
and she could use fans to mix the smoke
and pollution with outside air.
Ava should also install a
carbon monoxide detector
to make sure that the air is safe.
A carbon monoxide detector
could also detect leaks
from natural gas stoves or heaters.
It's also possible that Ava's
house has natural pollutants,
like mold, dust, or even radon.
Mold is a type of microscopic fungus
that's always floating around in the air,
and breathing it in can cause
itchy eyes, runny noses,
and it can trigger asthma attacks.
And mold loves moisture.
So, when the air is really humid,
there will be more mold spores,
which is good for the molds,
but bad for us.
And what areas of the house
tend to have the most moisture?
The bathrooms and the kitchen,
so these areas especially
need to have windows
that can be opened or air
fans that can draw moisture
and the molds outta the house.
Another kind of natural
indoor air pollutant is radon,
which is a radioactive noble gas.
It's produced by the natural decay
of radioactive rocks in the ground.
Let's say that Ava's
basement has some cracks
in the foundation and the walls.
That would mean that
when radon seeps upward
through the soil, it
could enter these cracks
and be stuck inside Ava's house.
Breathing in too much radon
could damage lung tissue
and even lead to lung cancer,
depending on where the house is built.
Some places, like Ava's house,
are more likely to have radon than others.
Ava can prevent radon exposure
by sealing up the cracks
in the foundation of her house
and by ventilating her basement.
Some indoor air pollution
requires professional remediation.
To get rid of asbestos, for example,
an accredited asbestos
abatement specialist
basically shows up in a
biohazard suit like this.
That's how dangerous it is.
For other situations,
there's a simple solution to
Ava's problem: ventilation.
Ava could open windows
on the opposing sides of
her home just a crack.
The outdoor air would flow in,
dilute the indoor air pollutants,
and carry them outta the house.
This natural ventilation
allows the air to circulate
and reduces the buildup
of indoor air pollutants.
There are a lot of ways
that indoor air pollutants
could sneak into Ava's house, from nature,
from combustion, and
from human-made items.
Being aware of these sources can help Ava
make sure that the air inside her house
is fresh, clean, and healthy.